Spacex's starship has experienced more than a few crashes or explosions during
un crewed sub orbital testing,
some more dramatic than others.
On Monday,
SpaceX ended up pushing off the first major flight of both stages of starship due to
what Ceo Elon Musk called a frozen pressure valve.
We are going to stop the launch for today.
The road for testing and verifying that starship can be
operated and used the way SpaceX has set out to use.
It is long and hard.
Here's some of the challenges SpaceX faces getting its biggest and most powerful rocket
off of and back on the ground.
SpaceX has been developing starship over the last several years aiming to create a
reusable rocket to one day handle ambitious crude missions to deep space.
The rocket is made up of a 226 ft tall booster called super heavy that would
power a 164 ft tall spacecraft so called starship super
heavy.
The booster with the starship spacecraft docked on top of it that's never flown before.
This is all brand new.
Musk has sought to temper expectations,
telling listeners during a Twitter discussion that the company faces serious challenges pulling
off the operation.
Musk has pointed to starships engines as among his top concerns going into the flight
attempt at one point comparing them to grenades.
The engines called raptors were designed in house at SpaceX.
33 are installed on the vehicles booster.
The power SpaceX has tried to build into the super heavy
booster creates relatively more risk than say a smaller
rocket with lesser engines that aren't designed to offer as much,
you know,
thrust as much power to get to space.
Former employees have said risk taking is encouraged at the company to gain data to make
improvements so long as that doesn't create safety risks.
The goal isn't to simply blow stuff up.
The goal is to try to hit milestones deal with anomalies and
problems that may emerge and and make the vehicle better quickly
heading back to the landing zone.
SpaceX has also successfully landed the starship spacecraft on its fifth
attempt.
It landed back on its path after climbing as high as 6.2 miles during a six minute
flight in 2021.
If all goes to Spacex's plan,
the starship spacecraft would fly around 90 minutes during the flight test.
After it separates from the booster,
the booster would then land in the Gulf of Mexico while the ship would land in the Pacific Ocean.
But it will need to undergo some stress tests to get to that point if they're able
to blast the rocket off a minute that the vehicle
will experience what's called Max Q.
It's basically the moment where there's the,
the peak amount of mechanical stress on the rocket if they get
through that and the starship spacecraft is able to separate and begin flying
on its own.
That's arguably the,
the second big milestone in the mission.